[Music]
hey everyone Welcome to our podcast High
School memories where we explore the
issues that shape the lives of young
people today I'm your host medika and in
today's episode we'll delve into the
fascinating and often complex world of
peer pressure in schools and how can
influence the decision making process of
teenagers this topic is very
crucial as understanding the Dynamics of
peer pressure Can Shed light on how
teens make choices that affect their
academic social and their personal lives
so let's begin by defining what peer
pressure is peer pressure is the
influence that friends classmates or
peers will exert on one another often to
confirm to certain behaviors attitudes
or
expectations this influence can be both
positive and negative so let's start
with the Positive peer
pressure which uh positive effects of
peer pressure in a classroom
include motivation collaboration between
peers um adaptations to positive
behaviors greater norms and values
healthy competition
Etc positive peer pressure can really
motivate students to work harder and
perform better academically because when
they see their peers actively engaged in
the learning process then they're most
likely more likely to follow
suit um peer pressure positive peer
pressure can also encourage
collaboration or teamk work since
students may feel compelled to
participate in group projects or even
study sessions which can enhance their
learning experience and their social
skills at the same
time positive peer pressure can
encourage um teenagers to build positive
relationships to develop empathy
practice effective
communication it can also create a
healthy sense of competition which
pushes students to strive for excellence
so for example when students observe
their peers achieving academical success
they are they may be motivated to set
Higher Goals for themselves for example
I have been a healthy competitor as well
CU because when I've seen um or if I've
been surrounded by people who strive to
for example do good at a test or be the
Best in Class then of course we others
or I felt compelled to do the same so
I'm thankful to be a part of a classroom
where peer pressure was mostly
positive classroom peer pressure can
also help establish and
reinforce positive norms and values for
example when students encourage each
other to act with respect honesty and
Integrity it can foster this positive
classroom
environment as well as students can
adapt to these positive behaviors such
as being punctual or participating in
class when they see their peers doing
the same thing so it's important to note
that the effectiveness of peer pressure
in promoting positive outcomes largely
depends on the classroom culture on the
teacher's guidance and in the nature of
peer
interactions teachers play a critical
role in the shaping in shaping the
classroom environment and harnessing PE
harnessing peer pressure for the benefit
of students they can encourage positive
behaviors uh Foster a supportive
learning atmosphere as well as
addressing the negative peer pressure
when it
arises on the flip side negative PE peer
pressure can be detrimental it can lead
to risky behaviors such as cheating or
substance abuse and even
bullying negative peer pressure can also
influence students to prioritize their
social acceptance
over sound decision
making the negative effects of peer
pressure are endless some of them can
include
academic
underperformance bullying risky Behavior
social exclusion
Etc in this environment students may be
may feel pressured to conform to a lower
standard of academic performance or
maybe discouraged totally from excelling
in their studies just to fit in with a
less academically inclined peer group
this was me before ISP where most of my
peers didn't value academic performance
as much as I did and to fit in I also
started to conform to lower standards
but I now highly regret those actions
peer pressure can sometimes lead to
bullying and harassment where students
Target their peers and this Behavior can
have severe emotional and psychological
consequences for the victims
negative peer pressure can encourage
students to engage in said risky
behaviors such as cheating or substance
abuse or other harmful activi activities
which can have long-term negative
consequences on the people's lives this
was also me a few years ago where if I
didn't do something my peer suggested or
I didn't behave in a specific way then I
was quote unquote betraying them or not
being part of the group and if I wanted
to resist this negative peer pressure I
was perceived as different or I may may
have experienced social exclusion and
isolation which uh can lead to feelings
of loneliness and
inadequacy students may also experience
lower self-esteem if they feel like they
don't measure up to St standards set by
their peer
group this pressure to conform to
negative peer Norms can lead to Stress
and Anxiety as students May constantly
worry about uh fitting in and or meeting
their peers' expectations again this was
an experience of mine I used to be so
self-aware about things I would say or
maybe even the way I was acting just so
I could fit in and um conform to those
negative
Norms uh next would be poor decision
making where negative peer pressure can
lead to impulsive and poor decision
making as students May prioritize social
acceptance over rational thinking and
good
judgment so I think it's important for
teachers and educational institutions to
address this negative peer pressure and
create a positive classroom culture that
which promotes cooperation promotes
empathy and respect while it discourages
negative behaviors
totally throughout the years where I had
been facing these say challenges I had
wished that teachers had taken more
control of the environment or the
classroom creating a safe and
comfortable learning space but I I ALS
Al wish I would have been more open to
my parents so the question may be posed
as how can parents and teachers help
teenagers to make better decisions in
the face of negative
pressure I brought this question up to
my parents whilst trying to put together
this episode and their answer was
something that they had always
encouraged all throughout growing up
which was to maintain open and nonjudge
mental communication with one another so
their aim was basically to create an
environment where we felt comfortable to
discuss uh these concerns of ours and
I'm very thankful to them for doing such
a great job of doing just that teachers
next as I said earlier should take
control of the class and shift the
class's focus from tearing each other
down and creating this hostile space in
the class to helping one another and
creating a safe learning
environment another question that might
be posed on the topic of peer pressure
is how do technology and social media
influence peer pressure in this dig
digital age that we live in and what can
teens and their parents do to manage
these pressures well firstly social
media platforms often promote this need
for likes shares comments and any other
type of interaction that may cause teens
to feel pressured to conform to popular
Trends or behave in a certain way just
to attract positive online attention
this ties in closely with comparison
culture which is a term you used to
describe these
curated or idealized versions of others
uh lives on social media where you might
be left feeling inadequate or not
popular or cool enough because you're
not like that one beauty influencer or
that famous
blogger worst of all these online
platforms are a breeding ground for
cyber cyber bullying which can lead
teens to make awful decisions just to
avoid this type of harass
assment so in conclusion pure pressure
is an integral part of the adolis
experience shaping the decisions that
teens make in school and
Beyond understanding both its positive
and negative uh aspects is crucial for
helping young people navigate these
formative years
successfully adults can play a pivotal
role in empowering teens to make
informed choices and ultimately prepare
them for the challenges and
opportunities that lie ahead thanks for
joining us on this journey through the
world of peer pressure in schools until
next time stay curious and
compassionate if you found this episode
informative and engaging please consider
subscribing leaving a review and sharing
it with others your support helps us
continue our mission to explore the
issues that matter most to young people
thank
[Music]
you
oh